le meilleur moyen de lutter contre une
phobie c'est d'éduquer les gens et le
problème dans ce dans ce cas de figure
c'est que on entend très rarement parler
des personnes transgenres et là pour la
première fois potentiellement la voie
d'une tranche jean va être écoutés c'est
à miss france pourquoi je termine mon
propos si tu me permet bien sûr le
plaisir donc moi je trouve que c'est
vraiment une excellente chose en plus
elle est très jolie moi je n'attends
qu'une chose c'est qu'elle puisse
s'exprimer pour qu'elle nous parle un
petit peu de sa différence et puis quel
cas les ducs un peu les gens pour qu'ils
acceptent mieux les femmes transgenres
alors bonne à carla alors moi il ya trop
de points sur lesquels
j'aimerais j'aimerais échanger les
éléments dit si tu étais pas c'est déjà
sur les règles direct de miss france je
croyais donc quand on veut postuler pour
pour pour se présenter à miss france il
ya déjà la question est ce que on est
une femme
ça c'est une grande question c'est
peut-être hors sujet mais en tout cas
moi je pense que non parce qu'il ya
plein de 2 comment dire de
d'études qui ont été établis et ça
prouve que ce n'est pas une femme déjà
bien 6
on dit que normalement on est pas tous
avoir fait de la chirurgie sauf si elle
et réparatrice malbon patrice la sarre
et par desalle et par quoi ça répare le
cinquième essai par un accident de voie
la paille à lausanne à 6 min on est
particulièrement intolérants lâcheront
pas vraiment le tout mais vraiment
non mais c'était c'est le jugement des
valeurs c'est juste que c'est un sujet
suprême important et on verra mais
comment
les importants
c'est le sait la communication que ça
fait là dessus sur les jeunes filles qui
veulent se présenter on parle pas de la
boucherie qui est faite sur ces
transgenres
mais vous savez ce que c'est
la promotion on en fait toujours la
promotion qu'on dit c'est ça ils ont
déjà
le parcours de quatre
mois par les vous savez les traitements
hormonaux ont fait sur ces gens là où tu
parleras après vous savez les
traitements hormonaux c'est leur choix
et vit bien sûr mais on s'érige haine et
il faut absolument des photos mais ici
il va seulement le mans joue absolument
en parler c'est aussi important c'est
c'est pas c'est pas on risque de devenir
un homme cette répartition des rôles si
vous dérange aussi c'est qu'il ya des
règles non mr ce que vous dites vous
avez été nommé moi c'était une idée en
fait on s'est tous posé la question
quand on était une jeune fille je pense
que toi tu perds moi je moi je me suis
posé la question oui bon
on sait tout de poser la question si au
début je me suis fait circoncire jeudi
d'enlever tout et puis
c'est vrai voilà alors oui et donc oui
mais je me suis posé la question et j'ai
été regardé sur internet et j'ai vu qu
étant donné que je faisais un mètre
soixante deux c'était pas possible avec
la taille minimum sermet 75,6 être
utilisée sans subvention
de 10 en 12 mois donc voila moi je
trouve ça injuste
pour les femmes qui veulent se présenter
qui ne peuvent pas et donc si on doit
être dans la totale
comment dire tout à l'ouverture dans ces
cas là on accepte les femmes qui n'ont
pas la taille requise je suis d'accord
sur ce point là mais on n'est pas obligé
de détruire une un autre type de femmes
qui sont les femmes transgenres et j'ai
dès son arrivée pas des femmes non parce
que vous avez un désir en qui j'ai hyper
accablant pour les a toujours les mêmes
bayonnais même guillaume genton qui dit
non je dois avoir un autre nom c'est une
bonne nouvelle moi ce qui me gêne c'est
que c'est pas sincère en fait tous a
repris à fait penser à une énorme
opération de communication et de
marketing de la part de tf1 du comité
miss france pour que miss france perde
un peu son image sexiste et réac
regarder le timing des événements en
septembre 2020 ils sortent un film sur
une miss transgenres avec sylvie tellier
dedans en 2021 ils sortent un film idéal
avec andrea furet dedans sylvie telle il
a annoncé son départ donc forcément ça
marque une rupture et line nous annonce
que la même actrice de ce film va être
candidate on sait qu'elle va gagner miss
paris on sait qu'elle va gagner miss ile
de france moi ça n'a pas l'air sincère
c'est juste pour que miss france perde
son collimateur celle ci s'était servi
tellier canada son mari s'était prononcé
elle avait dit voilà moi j'imaginerais
pas qu'une miss transgenres pour être
élue miss france
sylvie tellier c'est la nouvelle
production le marquer une rupture avec
montserrat des romains on a appelé les
producteurs de miss france dans les
cales et enjouée rade il n'y a pas de
sujet pour nous il n'y a aucun sujet